we just reached an entirely new
milestone in space exploration
a mission could go to a comet drill out
a sample and to bring it back to earth
the European Space Agency's Rosetta
spacecraft just landed a small 220 pound
robot onto a comment making it the
seventh celestial body we've ever landed
a spacecraft on previous missions have
flown by comets and in 2005 NASA
intentionally crashed a spacecraft into
a comet to analyze its interior but this
is the first mission to make a
controlled landing on one comets are
frigid chunks of ice and rock that orbit
the Sun they're a bit like asteroids
except they have more elliptical orbits
that sometimes take them so close to the
Sun that they start to vaporize creating
the bright tails they're known for
scientists think comets may have brought
water and complex organic molecules to
earth which we can thank for our
existence the common in question is
called 67p cg named after ukrainian
astronomers who first spotted it in 1969
it's sort of duck shaped and about two
and a half miles wide picture a rock the
size of Japan's Mount Fuji rotating
every 12 hours and moving through space
at about 84,000 miles per hour millions
of miles away from Earth comet 67p
orbits the Sun every six-and-a-half
years from a point just beyond Jupiter
to reach it Rosetta had to loop around
several times passing by Earth and Mars
to use their gravity as a slingshot as a
result it's been traveling for more than
a decade nope it left earth way back in
March of 2004 and has traveled over 3.5
billion miles to reach the comet
that's nearly 40 times the distance from
the earth to the Sun as it traveled too
far to be powered by the Sun the
spacecraft went into hibernation for two
and a half years on the way there
Rosetta woke up at the beginning of this
year and caught up with a comment
anonymous just putting the probe in
orbit around the comet was a major feat
we'd never done that before
especially since engineers expected a
potato-shaped comet and ended up with a
duck last month scientists picked out a
site field lander a nice smooth flat
spot on the comet smaller lobe the
lander flew down to the comet over the
course of several hours slowing itself
down and eventually
the speed of a person walking here we
have very very low gravity so this land
of Richmond has a mass of about a
hundred kilogram will have been weight
off about a sheet of paper when it comes
down on the column the problem is to
stay there after ten years of flight the
lander has an incredibly short amount of
time to conduct science on the Comets
surface 64 hours
that's how long his battery lasts and
that's how long it has to drill into the
comet collect soil samples and
chemically analyze them after that the
lander deactivates unless can get enough
solar power to recharge but Rosetta will
continue to orbit the comet and keep
sending back photos and other data until
December 2015 when the comet heads back
out of the inner solar system
all this research will tell us more
about the composition of comets than
we've ever known before and because
comets are the oldest things we can
reach this information could help us
better understand the very beginnings of
our solar system
you
[Music]